America a child is dead two months old
the youngest of eight children she was a
casualty of poverty another mouth to
feed and a family were already there was
too little to eat
she died of protein deficiency and
malnutrition and her father who was in
another town did not come to her funeral
he could not afford to make the trip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this infant's death is not unique in
countries throughout the developing
world the death of little children is
one of the daily tragedies of life
[Music]
though we usually think of the problem
of an exploding population in terms such
as economic development overcrowding
underemployment ecology education
maternal health and personal freedom it
has come down for these people on this
day to a matter of life and death
[Music]
she's not dying from starvation in
underdeveloped countries in children
dying in the words there is no much
difference
they are both murdered unsquare about
the population the whole world but
especially in El Salvador which is a
paper I leave for my children are my
wife might work anything I need some
scary course that's why I'm working here
yes I think is that for the situation
but somebody has to so somebody has to
do something we have to do something and
when I say something I am complaining
because I want a very strong in
aggressive policy in population if this
country is going to be a country a
little country within 20 years
[Music]
El Salvador has the highest population
density in Latin America and one of the
highest population growth rates in the
world there are three and a half million
people here now and if something is not
done there will be seven million in 20
years already one can see what this
might mean in terms of human degradation
[Music]
although health Salvador does not have
an official population policy people
like dr. Madrigal are working to meet
the challenge but in the mean time human
tragedies occur I can't tell you what my
name is I'll show you my face I'll tell
you the name of the hospital we are in
but I really want you to see this is
terrible this girl is anne-marie and
she's been here for about six weeks
playing very close to death from an
illegal abortion this is not a unique
case we have more than 60,000 cases like
this a year
this is no country alone as a doctor I
feel that his family planning services
will know widely available tragedies
like this would never have the great
number of illegal abortion throughout
Latin America and the risks taken by
women who seek them his powerful proof
of the desire by these women for a way
to control the size of their family dr.
Vernon Madrigal wants them to have an
alternative to butchery among his many
interests is female
sterilization these babies are 42 years
old lady she has have six children and
his song 11 I think to five years old
and she's been taking pills in the last
five years so she's so nervous and shoot
she's so anxious to about the problem
that she decided to ask us for
sterilizer and we're doing it with a new
method called
novel topic tubal ligation I am the
grantee of fact-finding so we're working
for the ether and my father will provide
the funds to do 300 fumigations in one
year
okay come in for my thing us time we've
already she's on their local lemon
theater she's not on the general
anesthesia which represents a great
advantage because the lady can be
operated for hours dr. Madrigal got his
laparoscope from a pathfinder fund an
american foundation concerned with
population in developing countries along
with pathfinder and other groups the
Agency for International Development AI
dee'
the largest source of assistance and
funding in the field is helping in an
international assault upon the most
pressing problem of the 20th century you
know that's all yes the Familia no
muchas gracias
[Applause]
some places in El Salvador are very
difficult to get to but getting there is
part of winning the battle in health and
family planning the nights that I came
with came because there's a bottle of
health in the family after she tries to
resolve this problem she will talk to
her family about preventive medicine and
family planning ideas supporting her in
this effort education is an important
part of the population program in El
Salvador in a few years these children
will be in the prime reproductive age
group and then will have the knowledge
to make intelligent decisions about
family size on the other side of the
world the governor of a Philippine
province spends 30 percent of his time
talking about family planning right dr.
Madrid Gao governor san luis is
convinced that unchecked population
growth is the greatest threat to his
country
and the Philippines one finds the
problems of El Salvador reflected on a
huge scale in 1970 the government
established a population policy the
result in a short time the Philippines
has developed a diverse far-reaching
family planning program potentially one
of the most effective in Southeast Asia
with help from international agencies
large input from a ID and the energetic
efforts of philippine officials and
volunteers the challenge is finally
being faced is it too late no one can
say for sure
a traditional agricultural economy is
giving way to industrialization the
country is in the throes of a vast
migration from farms to cities Manila is
or the crowded mired in smog and it
spawned those slums are among the worst
in the world our show today but more
than 70 percent a lot of people who
belong to be poverty line live within
poverty line I know for a fact there are
1.5 million families in the Philippines
who live below the subsistence level and
with the proceeds growth rate of 3.1 of
Philippine population you can just
imagine how disastrous this would be for
the future of our social and economic
development as a Peace Corps volunteer
here in the Philippines
you see many different developmental
projects and there are projects in
agriculture education infrastructure and
yet all of these projects are diminished
because of the vast population problem
in this country so I feel as a volunteer
working here it's been very rewarding to
be in this kind of program that's at the
crux of the matter
children who are at the crux of the
matter in a class on population
awareness in elementary school in
Cabanatuan City second-grade students
play a game how many of them can fit
into a limited space before the
overcrowding becomes unbearable
how far can they be pressed before the
game suddenly becomes unfunny that faded
man and all the beings in this earth and
by nature they're also features rebus
created us and it is one of the things
that the God has given us in order to
you should be able to survive so every
month I need to resurface and in our
family planning program we are
exploiting the surface news Atman in
order that we can fish through our
family planning program why the worst we
know very well that over and above the
laws of God the laws of society they
love discover which is one of the
expressions of selfishness of man they
love the saga so if you go to the
barriers and tell the people during the
body is bad or you can help the world
the country the embracing family
planning there is definition to you but
he tell them will help
it contains the farm running program
you'd be healthy of children in other
that they will not be undernourished in
order they will be able to the preschool
so that you then give them a higher
degree of education it will be a very
effective way much more effective and
that is what we are learning
when Governor Sam Lewis began his family
planning programs in Laguna he met
resistance from the Catholic Church
now the responsible parenthood Council a
Catholic organization is working on
population volunteer couple to visit
people in their homes to discuss the
living method in Quebec province
commander Borja and his wife have made
more than 50 such visits how are they
doing the new grid says the commander so
far nobody's pregnant the home visit
approach to family planning has no
national boundaries in the mining town
of bony Hills in Liberia the port coy
has been a professional visitor for four
years in that time he's called a house
after house on behalf of the Family
Planning Association of Liberia
explaining to parents how they can
restrict the size of their families
later many of these people have shown up
at the Bomi Hills clinic which dispenses
the largest sort of birth prevention
devices
Liberia has a relatively small
population and is not yet embroiled in a
population crisis but the infant
mortality rate here is high and mother
child healthcare is below an acceptable
standard so the government has no
official population policy the Family
Planning Association of Liberia a
private group supported by the
International Planned Parenthood
Federation supplies family planning
services for those who wish them
emphasizes the health and welfare of
mothers and babies and instructs women
on the proper spacing of children
for some tree of life thickening here
you fill it up water of the castle
that's how much is really supposed to
have okay now make sure water is boiled
before you can't repeat the baby you
wash your hands
mr. William Hill administrative
secretary of the Family Planning
Association of Liberia came to the
University of Chicago to study advanced
techniques in population communications
mr. hills training in Chicago is part of
a huge effort and manpower development
essential to the worldwide population
movement over the next 10 years the
movement needs more than 50 thousand
physicians 150,000 nurses
100,000 Health and Family Planning home
visitors thousands more medical and
social workers health and family life
education demographers behavioral
scientists and communications and
training expose the infesting thought if
it's a faith as a different faith you
should have the eyes in the middle
[Music]
after mainland China the most populous
country on earth over half a billion
people if the growth rate is not checked
there will be more than a billion people
by the year 2000 the effort here has
been enormous the oldest and one of the
largest official family planning
programs in the world
20 years of labor by hundreds of
thousands of people the goal lower the
birth rate by 40% over the next 10 years
in India they use the cafeteria approach
making a wide range of birth prevention
methods easily available sterilization
intrauterine devices condoms and other
conventional contraceptives including
pills and selected projects however
sterilization is the mainstay of the
program in the city of Kannan or in
Kerala State one of the great
innovations of the Indian effort a
vasectomy camp an intensive campaign to
perform more than 15,000 operations in
30 days for the operation yeah
now we could control this is the control
room where all the activities of the
here we find all the people lined up for
the operation they're coming from all
over the care district and not only from
this this is for mother other places
also parent and Sangha I throw a side
effect his name is Shankaran using he's
38 years old
Munna he says he has three children by
the kiss relation for his wife is 30
years old
why do you come here under oppression
nicotine habit witness I say done he
said he doesn't want any more children
he had three already married as a mother
in general he says his wife is willing
and yes no objections not not as his
wife have any objections for the
operation the operation takes less than
10 minutes can be performed with
scarcely the loss of a single drop of
blood one camp in Gujarat state doctors
perform the incredible number of 223,000
vasectomies in 60 days there's a
carnival atmosphere at the massive
Cannes programs of live entertainment
and songs and dances about the name for
family clan prizes reduce the war
anything was here that a whole people is
behind this effort of Indians regard
Family Planning as a patriotic youth in
1971 the Indian Parliament legalized
abortion as a maternal health measure
part of a pattern of changing laws
throughout the world in Bombay
if the world's first hospital devoted
solely to family plan surgeons have
devised a method of performing an
abortion and a tube ectomy at the same
time the Bombay program is the
brainchild of dr. Babcock you know what
I think they're fantastic bacon
more than 700,000 people pass everything
and it is here that the family planning
history was made in a city where there
was only one materialization per day
after setting up an operation theater
here we started doing 100 200 300
operations every day
centuries ago Arab tribesmen discovered
that if a small pebble is placed in the
uterus of a female camel that camel will
not become pregnant the deletion
Institute of Family Planning and
maternal child health has chosen macam
first animal to practice family planning
as the symbol of its program and the
bearer of an important message to the
Phoenician people
Phoenician Family Planning officials
meet with representatives of foreign
agencies concerned with population
doctor from the United Nations World
Health Organization a nurse midwife from
the Swedish International Development
Authority demographers from the
population council representatives of AI
D and doctors communicators and
demographers from other groups their
meetings such as this in all the
countries committed to population action
the challenge is worldwide response his
international community standing in the
courtyard of the Great Mosque of
carillon Imam Muhammad Ali tribe says
that family planning is not contrary to
Islam and when is necessary for the
economic development of the Tunisian
nation religious leaders throughout the
world are conscious of the population
problem and many of them have found that
the idea of family planning is
consistent with their religious
principle
[Applause]
the role of women in Arab society is
changing many have rejected their
traditional role and now practice family
planning dr. Ben shaped a leader in the
struggle for women's rights and the
first female doctor in Tunisia devotes
all of her time to family planning
counseling and clinical work in talisha
as in many other countries the
postpartum approach has been extremely
successful immediately following the
delivery of a child women are especially
responsive to a visit by a family
planning worker providing information on
contraceptive method
but it is not enough to confine the work
to clinics or to wait for people to
appear family planning workers must
visit remote areas bringing information
and services and a special kind of human
understand the key to all family
planning programs is the winning of
acceptance well the women were what
contacted accept the methods that are
available approaches the same everywhere
in Tunisia in South Korea in every
country in the world one woman was
taught to remove it
you must be sympathetic and prent
the home visit in a rural area is like a
ritual lonely walked greeting the
establishment a rep for the opening of a
briefcase to display an explanation of
available device a women who do this
work or a new breed of missionaries and
they often speak of their reward the
sense of personal accomplishment and
they win another woman open when they
achieved the break field called
acceptance South Korea more than 32
million people a rapidly developing
nation has reduced its growth rate by
one third in ten years
the goal for 1976 another 1/4 decrease
in the streets of Seoul one senses the
dynamism and discipline that a people
whose country has been transformed from
rural to urban than farming to an
industrial power in a few short years
South Korea is one of the few success
stories in the battle against an
exploding population and the Kaleem
accomplishment is a valid inspiration to
the developing world that was not easily
achieved the first year birthday party
of a male child this is a traditional
ceremony in Korea but a preference for
sons was long a barrier to family
planning but the country is changing
urbanization is leading to a desire for
smaller families women are becoming
better educated but the key factor is
the commitment of the Korean government
it has taken 10 years of hard work to
turn the growth rate statistics around
faced by population disaster a decade
ago
Korea has mounted an extensive program
training communication collection and
use of demographic data the network of
mothers clubs for family planning
promotion and even the manufacture of
funding within this factory of onion
since 1955 the United States through the
agency's International Development has
provided rapidly increasing support for
population and family planning programs
throughout the developing world we found
channeled through many organizations now
especially the United Nation and gone
for a broad stretch of action including
research and the provision of
contraceptives button leads especially
all contraceptive provided for the for
women and couples in the developing
countries can control their fertility as
they wish to improve their health and
well-being
the birth of a child is always America
even to those who have seen at many
times in South Korea today a birth is a
more joyous miracle than in most
developing countries because as a result
of an intensive program of family
planning the future of a child is far
brighter
there should be no starvation for this
Korean baby
the chances good that he will have an
education a job in a dynamic economy a
decent environment and perhaps most
important a sense of dignity if such
things can happen in Korea then they can
be made to happen everywhere
Latin America a child bath in Korea a
child is born children are the future
and their destiny is in our hand if the
population challenge is met then the
future holds great promise if it is not
met well it must be met because when we
speak of population we are speaking of
the future of the human race